Donald Trump was interviewed this morning
on Fox News by brown nosing sycophant Maria
Bartiromo.
She was actually a pretty damn good financial
journalist 20 years ago.
I used to watch her when I was getting into
stock trading early in high school.
And now she is just a Trump suck up on the
Fox Business Network.
This interview aired this morning, but it
was previously recorded, as I gather, and
the interview was an absolutely unmitigated
house of horrors.
I want to go through some of the most bizarre
and disturbing moments with you.
We could spend all day just looking at this
interview.
But I want to pick just two important moments
of Maria Bartiromo gave Trump a softball interview
like she always does.
And yet Trump is so clueless.
His ignorance is so lethally weaponized that
even Maria Bartiromo couldn't save him with
softball questions.
So let's take a look now to get this first
thing out of the way.
The goalposts are again being moved on the
corona virus death toll now.
Trump is talking about we're going to have
more than 100000 deaths.
And that is a great victory because of how
much worse it could have been.
Check this out and look at how casually Trump
has doubled the expected number of deaths
from just three weeks ago and yet is still
calling it a victory thanks to him.
We're going to lose over a hundred thousand
perhaps in this country.
Now, in all fairness, that's at the bottom
level of the scale.
We would've lost 2 million.
We will lose more if we did it a different
way.
But you're talking about a hundred thousand
more, a little bit less.
More.
Who knows?
It's a terrible thing.
No.
So that can't be replaced.
We're spending trillions of dollars on all
of the damage economically, financially that
has caused.
So it is a terrible thing.
It's just an incredible thing.
So he says that's at the bottom.
We could have lost more than 2 million people.
So there are two important takeaways here.
Yesterday we did a debunking about we're now
testing as much as SouthKorea per capita.
Important to understand the genesis of that
disinformation.
I want you to now understand the genesis of
this 2million thing that we hear.
A couple of things that are important to know.
Number one, the goalposts have been moved
into the locker room and they will soon be
out in the parking lot for a month or longer,
Trump was talking about.
We may lose 60000 people.
And that's going to be a really great job
that we'll have done.
We blew past 60000 deaths.
So Trump starts talking about, listen.
We could lose seventy or eighty thousand people.
We hit 70 and Trump started talking about
could be 90 to 100000.
Now, Trump is cavalierly and casually saying,
I'm going to lose more than one hundred thousand
people.
And as long as he always predicts a number
slightly larger than what we have.
Eventually he's going to be right.
Eventually he will say, you know, we're gonna
lose 200000 maybe, and we'll get to 1 95.
And he'll say we stayed under it.
40 percent of the country falls for it.
40 percent of the country will hear this and
believe Trump knows what he's talking about.
No matter how how many times he shifts the
number.
More importantly, here's what I really want
people to understand.
This comparison of the death toll always to
2.2 or 2.5 million, the deaths we could have
had if Donald Trump didn't act, understand
that 2 million deaths is if literally nothing
is done.
Now, this would be impossible because governors
do.
Excuse me, do things.
There is not going to be any scenario where
governors were doing nothing.
In fact, the governors did stuff before Trump
did.
We saw stay at home orders and starting to
quarantine and the like at the state level
before Trump did anything.
So when Trump says understand where 2million
comes from, 2 million is.
We have 331 million people in the country,
70 percent of the country gets the virus.
That would get us to herd immunity if 70 percent
got the virus.
That means about 230 million people get the
virus.
We expect an infection fatality rate, not
a case fatality rate, an infection fatality
rate of about 1 percent.
1 percent of 231 million is 2.3 million.
So that is literally no mitigation.
So when Trump says, listen, we're going to
lose 100000 instead of 2 million, thanks to
me, it's a worthless comparison that says
nothing at all about Donald Trump's response.
The important point is we're now at eighty
five thousand deaths were expected to hit
100000 in about a week or 10 days.
The numbers will continue climbing, but Trump
will claim victory no matter the death number,
because he has set 2.2, 2.3 million as the
bar that he is keeping us below.
Next clip, clip of Trump exhibiting such a
poor understanding of trade, economics and
manufacturing and foreign policy that he actually
says if we end our relationship with China,
our financial relationship, our relationship
of trade, we would save $500 billion.
I'm going to play the clip.
Trump seems to think if we just we stop importing
and exporting with China.
We, quote, save 500 billion.
Take a look at this.
He spoke to Xi Jinping.
I have a very good relationship, but I just
right now, I don't want to speak to him.
I don't want to speak because, you know, Senator
Cotton was saying maybe we should be limiting
the amount of visas that we give to students
who want to study things like.
There are many things and there are many things
we could do.
We could do things.
We could cut off the whole relationship.
Now, if you did, what would happen?
You'd say 500 million dollars if you cut off
the whole relationship.
Look at what point does it.
And I said this for years.
I said it with other countries also.
You know, John is not the only country ripping
us off.
This is one of the most incoherent things
that Trump has actually said in his presidency.
And I can explain to you why.
First, there is this idea that we we save
500 billion.
I believe what Trump is talking about is our
trade deficit with China.
As recently as a couple of years ago, I had
trouble finding the numbers from from last
year.
But a couple of years ago, we had a $500 billion
trade deficit with China.
What that means is we import 500 billion more
in products from China than we export to China.
We have a deficit of $500 billion.
So it seems that Trump, who has the economics
understanding of a fruit fly, thinks if we
cancel all trade, we end up at zeros, meaning
the five hundred billion deficit goes away.
And it's like saving $500 billion.
Now, this is not how trade and economies work.
The $500 billion trade deficit with China
would go away if we were to stop all trade
with China.
Maybe it doesn't even really work that way.
But then we would have a massive deficit in
terms of the products that we all take for
granted and then prices would explode on a
whole bunch of stuff because our economy is
based on cheap stuff from China.
We would have to there's a couple options
if we stop trade with China.
On the one side for importing, we either have
to import from other countries the stuff we
get from China, which just shifts the trade
deficit.
And it would explode demand for these products
in the new countries.
We deal with bringing up the prices.
That doesn't sound too good for American businesses
and individuals if we decide to manufacture
all of the stuff we get from China internally,
I mean, it would be impossible.
But imagine that we did it with eight years
to build those supply chains.
But imagine we did it.
Stuff would cost way, way more because the
reason we get these things from China is because
they're cheaper and our economy is based on
that.
And then you also have to remember a ton of
our businesses would fail if we stop exporting
to China, as Trump says, which would save
us 500 billion, as he puts it.
All of these American businesses that are
exporting to China go under.
What do you think the economic impact would
be of that on employment, on disposable incomes,
on the stock prices, as Trump might see it,
of these companies?
This is so absurd and crazy, and it is almost
inconceivable that an American president would
have such a lack of basic economic understanding.
And Maria Bartiromo, through no fault of her
own, she's a disastrous Trump brownnoser through
no fault of her own.
She has exposed Trump in this interview as
completely and utterly clueless, not just
on Corona virus.
We knew that, but also clueless on economics
to a degree that even those of us following
this for the last.
New Years would arguably be stunned and appalled
by no understanding whatsoever.
We're going to have more about this on the
David Pakman show, Instagram.
That's David Pakman show on Instagram.
Also on my personal Instagram, it is planting
day today.
We are past the frost here in Boston.
Follow me at David Pakman on Instagram to
follow the urban gardening attempt.
There are a lot happening there in the next
24 hours.